[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre ph content avec
moi d'une plante alors aujourd'hui pour
ceux qui sont sur youtube on apprend le
décor habituel on t'a québec dans mon
studio musique danse où sont mes parents
m'ont le coriace avec nous et qui
caillassent québec puis carrière ce qui
rapport qui ait lancé son nouvel album
la nuit des longs couteaux
ouais si vous écoutez vous aimez ce que
vous voyez vous pouvez vous abonner à
notre chaîne pour être à l'affût des
derniers podcasts que vous puissiez les
laisser dans les commentaires
les personnes que vous voulez qu'on
évite grillage merci beaucoup d'être là
merci à toi ph la finalisation je suis
pas content d'être là ça paraissait pas
de casse comme chase et puis je console
femmes c'est cool tu es un fan de
podcasts je commence en fait à découvrir
les podcasts neigeux comme je disais
chauffe un jogging pour 6 stand up puis
pauvreté tout ce qui fait puis j'ai
découvert son podcast d'ogden justement
qui a commencé ici à lavau de bois donc
c'est sûr que seules formes ok super
intéressant qui nous offre l'occasion de
vraiment de d'élaborer sur des questions
plus qu'une entrevue meute on le trouve
meilleur a pas de casque à 1,15 shologan
les écouter son show ouais j'ai écouté
ces derniers sont spéciale show soins
mais effectivement moi je préfère sa
personnalité d'interviews de personnes
avant d'avoir des bonnes conversations
que son stand plus grande ouverture
d'esprit dans ces podcasts dans son show
oui c'est un peu plus limitée qu'au
moins un peu moins élaborés sur une
chose parce que si il fait exprès aussi
des sachets sur la ligne d inacceptable
jetables il faudrait juste pour
provoquer une bonne ligne sa sélection
l'aiment beaucoup puis dernièrement a eu
le pack castrais qui le match que je
postule écouter
littéralement il est mal ça marche on
comprendrait on a des fois qu'un qu'on
regarde déjà comme ça tu sais on dirait
que sont pas dans surprenant même sont
pas la même espèce que les autres car
des gens comme ça on dirait qu'il lui
vraiment oui déconnecté mais pas juste
des connectés dans l'une il on dirait
qu'il est vraiment un autre et c'est une
autre espèce complètement connecté sur
mars mais lui c'est un petit 6 mars les
légendes de thézan supérieur comme lui
moi ça me fascine
non je parle fasciné par gens comme ça
moi c'est déjà comme saks devant des
gens comme ça que je suis un peu star
trak si les rencontres etc qui tiennent
beaucoup qui sont strokes parce que
quelqu'un ait connu moussa trousseau
c'est vraiment des gens comme ce qui
m'impressionne ma maison je trouve la
glorification des gens connus sont un
peu c'est un petit peu dommage qu'ici
c'est beaucoup et c'est ça les gens qui
changent le monde
concrètement tricot mais bon les gens
dans le domaine de la santé maintenant
j'ai un respect et une admiration
immense pour les gens qui travaillent là
dedans c'est lorsque ces grandes dédié
sa vie au service de la santé des gens
parce que c'est super de voir dans ce
bref très bien je préparais longtemps le
sommet mais personne n'est d'accord avec
toi sur le fait qu'ils aient maintenant
dans les podcasts qu'on a fait de si
c'est lui qui était le plus tard strokes
et prend le manga brianna doute bout à
cause d'un certain que c'est pas lui qui
le sauve qui est justement à cause qui
guy tellement bon est ce qu'il fait
c'est ce qui m'impressionne c'est plus
peu importe l'allégeance politique s'il
faut reconnaître que le gorille est faux
king bon est une machine et puis c'est
comme le talent pile intelligente et
skull
crise et que j'étais intimidé plus
quelqu'un connu et ouais puissant
politicien sincère comme les autres
membres de québec solidaire centre de
lille en ce moment je travaille dans le
milieu du livre de manama en sciences
pas m'appuyer hommen c'est une personne
réellement engagés qu'il fait pour les
bonnes raisons c'est ce qu'on se regarde
son parcours tout ce qu'elle a fait dans
sa vie au service vraiment des gens qui
sont défavorisés étaient en alcool
notaire notre jeu comme on dit il sa
maman est en manque de policiers qui
font ça pour des raisons réelles pts
sens artistique de gabriel en fait
partie je pense tout appuyé publiquement
et seuls les ânes et si oui oui parce
que l'année quand même que j'avais vu sa
conférence à trois rivières ça donne et
que je te l'ont même temps puis il va
donner une conférence sur l'indépendance
du québec pour convaincre les gens qui
viennent à la conférence
c'était dans le tas d'options nationale
où exactement il entend dorénavant qui
avant kiki merge qui si moi j'étais déjà
convaincu des jo pour plus sur le bar de
la souveraineté pour les avantages que
ça apporte métier jugez vous sa
confiance je tairai ans convaincu pour
plein de raisons qui m'a donné le livre
qui fait dire oui parce qu'il donne
gratuitement comme play l'argument pour
la souveraineté qui s'est sauvé deux
trois ans de sopi vu quelques fois puis
m'ont appuyé tu es à l'aide soins
sèchement de 202,6 depuis depuis l'année
passée aussi ma blonde et moi on se dit
on le fait moins vraiment vécu esprits
se sont échauffés sauter je me lève
c'est une fois publiquement ses bons à
la seule fois que je vais le faire j'ai
pas envie de me mettre dans un coin
c'est un bulletin publié en page qui je
travaille dans mon coin tu sais je
voulais des réellement pis puis ça a
porté fruit parce que l'iran très
différents ce qui est fait est rentré
parce que c'était quand même série non
j'espère juste parler beaucoup
d'artistes comme action c'est qu'ils ont
mis du leur juste pour que justement
pour qu'ils puissent rentrer ici pour
lui dans le coup de mou ces artistes qui
en accentuent leur faudrait pour qu ils
s en général
exactement le sol gelé rencontré l'agent
huit ans reste à mon prof de philo au
cégep
ah ouais
puis pauvre ségolène city il certains
profs qui tu marques dans une vie intime
tondant compte souvent sur les doigts
d'une main le genre tel prof au
secondaire puis saisonniers notre prof
d'anglais au secondaire et au cégep et
eux seuls le prof de philo puis c'est
vraiment les gars qui m'a au fait
intéressé justement à la philosophie
bien sonné ah oui à la souveraineté et
puis si je sors à la vie intellectuelle
mettons en général
puis je dois ce vraiment c'est un seul
franck ont justement les biens des profs
il ya aussi dans les professeurs qui
peuvent réellement changer des vies
concrètement le fabre les bonnes raisons
il a sa méthode faite en partie mises et
la bonne sortie si tu as fait tes
lancement au mois de septembre j'ai une
bonne et aria génial tu as beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup de fans en face aux stars à
briser la glace à l'intérieur je pense
faire un premier spectacle
après la chanson d'un album puis paul
rudd et souvent sur l'album love
ces lancements c'est le show de
lancement pour les fois qu'ils font des
choses lentement un peu plus de 5 à 7 15
ans exactement que par exemple au mois
de mars
on est en train de prévoir le lancement
de l'album c'est là les dates le qu'est
ce qu'on va faire comme ça surpris je
dois manger à vos propres salles à
montréal c'est l'as limitée soit quelque
chose ici avait accepté comme non ce
métro police choqué par fait 3/4 de
l'album est pas encore fait enregistrer
même pas encore composé suffit d'un peu
de l'album s'est composé écrit en deux
trois mois maintenant à faire le chantre
peu avant l'été pendant l'été puis enfin
que je me sois pas lancer dans le vide
moi j'ai besoin de sauge quand le besoin
d'un délai j'aime son travail est sous
pression plus besoin de travailler sous
pression des sinon je vois plus
je suis un peu procrastiner la dette ça
si près c'est de l'album finalement
qu'ils faisaient mais c'est aussi jean
mois de mars
l'on prévoit la date de sortie le 14
septembre de trois quarts il pas
facebook au métropolis m'écroule enfants
pleurent comme au quai sarrail mon album
bref le l'impérial
quand je vais te lancement grâce à la
première fois qu'on faisait le show on a
fait beaucoup de répétitions tous au
mess après il faut qu'on faisait
chauffer la glace pour les parieurs pour
le métropolis qui eux sont en 2d de
lancement d'aion supplémentaire du mt le
second janvier sur le site est très
excitant très content c'est
l'aboutissement en même temps de sa
marche soleil c'est cool avec télégramme
live s'ajoutent vraiment je trouve
qu'ils témoin qui est musicien aussi je
sais que c'est que dans la culture d'une
époque de façon d'avoir juste les tracts
et un dj pee mais même pas simplement
quelques uns des musiciens live trouve
que c'est vraiment valeur ajoutée une
baisse que c'est ce que ça ce que ça va
ajouter en fait c'est quand il ya moyen
de change un peu les chansons des
versions originales que joue la femme
d'affaires comme exemple j'ai fait des
matches pleins d'amour dans mon show
lancement d'un showcase train en tournée
j'ai mélangé des chansons des dix albums
précédents avec les nouvelles chansons
puis par sa soeur traque ça marche pas
vraiment faudrait le faire concrètement
changer le binge ans à mon studio
polémiques stupides c'est un peu
compliqué fac en live c'est beaucoup
plus sympa parce qu'on a toutes ces
séquences on a juste à jouer là-dedans
puis la dynamique avec le pire c'est que
je le fais aussi le spectre jeu ça
dépend des places on vous n'êtes pas du
budget de la capacité de risque
je suis un chausse l'organiser au
secondaire je n'ai pas vraiment d'idée
avec moi que c'est beaucoup plus simple
comme ça
bref j'aime aussi savoir les choses mais
c'est faux nous si on appelle j'avais vu
étrange menti dans toute la lignée des
mtv unplugged en tant que c'était
vraiment drôle et invités bail avec
djezzy mais moi cela qui m'a marqué le
plus elle est loin de ce poste j'ai vu
ça mais ironiquement les mtv unplugged
quand c'est des rapports
c'est là qu'ils plug la guide la benne
est sorti puis y est arrivé avec la
grosse guy et électriques restait ce
show en scène même cela de djezzy aussi
c'est qu'il pleuve le band au complet on
salive de la main et je m'appelle c'est
là que j'ai vu sur piste et je cherche
des jeunes d'écoles le trou je suppose
avec l âge mais j'étais vraiment trop
jeune pour lui le message que je voulais
être parlée par rapport à ceux justement
c'est de loin de sortir son puits il
s'inscrit un peu dans la même lignée que
les albums et pop qui sortent maintenant
avec vraiment beaucoup de trac le
streaming
puis ça fait que le sadi l'uimm tu peux
la qualité des trajets pression parce
que l'album est vraiment bon même chose
avec drake on en parlait l'autre avec
safia
c'est l'album i bon si tu prends
maintenant les onze tracter mais on dit
merde tracter mais ça fait un album
chose en écoutant scorpions ouais c'est
ce qui fait que tout positionné dans ça
parce que ton album qui fait clairement
pas ce nom fait qu'ils se pensent de
cette question là en fait il s'agit de
mon approche
mon approche les deux phares un album je
serai mandat prochain album come on
on écrit un livre où on fait un film
quelque chose qui est vraiment une ligne
qui vous livre mes traductions
développement une finale qui est moi
c'est ma façon de créer je suis pas
capable de le faire autrement
peut-être qu'à un moment donné je vois
que celle explorée passe autrement sauf
que ce que c'est ce que je trouve
dommage que je sois né puristes ou un
peu vieux mais je trouve ça dommage
l'expérience d'acheter un album de
l'écouté du début à la fin d'ouvrir le
livre est ce que moi j'aimais beaucoup
faire quand j'étais plus jeune c'est
maintenant moi même je ne fais plus
aussi sûre ce pas le faire pire pour
musique hors des pistes
ce super justement pour pouvoir de plus
de limites y ait plus de limites ce
qu'ils mangent mais je me ramène en
arrière quand j'avais mon ipod pimpi que
je mettais la musique c'était limité
j'avais juste le nombre de chansons que
je mettais sur mon ipod maintenant ça
existe plus et on ne sait c'est quand
même formidable c'est juste que les
désavantages qui viennent avec ce son là
aussi c'est moi c'est moins payant pour
les artistes
l'expérience justement d'écouter un
album ça se fait souvent la pièce une
chanson dans une pleine réussite et
cette chanson le sas enlève un peu
l'expérience d'écouter l'album propre
bac témoins attache émotivement à un
album physique tic était trop nélaton ch
pendant longtemps est un peu trop
scratch es6 sic en série est-ce que je
suis alors dit soit les clean coupe deux
fois mais faut me retournais
l'impression qu'un album physique qui
était au pic et love supreme dans ton
char le souvenir se sont chacune faisait
leafs terre il ya encore beaucoup de mes
fans qui achètent les copies physiques
justement parce que je mets un effort
même si dans une ère où le parce que
lorsqu'il y en a beaucoup moins qui se
vendent des alouettes ont mené au chaud
et ça finit en hausse pour musiquemag
mais moi je continue justement je
travaille ça murdoch qui est mon voisin
qui est que le métier de s'équiper 512
qui est qu' une maison des siens
dépendante de québec et qui font des
formes d'appui élaboré de cellulite
jamais des trucs codée sur la pochette
pis si tu mets dans cet angle là c'est
différent parce que les trucs comme
symétrie c'est quelque chose qui se
passe vraiment beaucoup mais lui c'est
l'inversé me met vraiment beaucoup de
temps sur leur toit et les vinyles moi
je continue à mettre la mettre cet
effort parce que je trouve ça important
de personnes c'est parce que c'est
quelque chose que j'aime faire aussi que
ce soit une oeuvre entière avec le
visuel et le duo de stéphanie finit
toujours par faire je n'y vais pas pour
l'heure suprême à qui ça se vend mollo
ça se vende un show le spot ça reste
quelque chose de limiter pour avoir ma
table tournante qu'il faut mais quand
même un retour à cette formule polie il
vrai collectionneur il ya quand même
beaucoup ça chaque cas chaque album fait
trois albums quelque chose que je ne
fais demande à chaque fois ils sont d
une raison de plus pour l'heure suprême
on a fait un premier un premier essai un
premier principe ça se vend pas aussi
avant les files pour pour le nouvel
album killer 3 doublement intéressant
parce que c'est vraiment beau à voir
ces gros personnes puis à la réception
d'un nouvel album
c'est très positif pour la banque qui
est facile fonctions c'est dans le
christ très personnel très exactement
puis adopté de leur vie et à 180 degrés
pour la proche pour l'enseignant avril
mais j'ai besoin de le faire
il est là et cette soirée bones moi si
je me subtil à chaque album je me suis
vraiment de ce que les gens vont en
penser un peu trop même qui se cet album
je me sens un peu débarrasser de ce
genre je voulu faire l'album que je
voulais pas pour moi en premier qui les
aurait des fans également sûrement ce
qui m'importe le plus les gens qui sont
autour de moi que je travaillerai
ressenti les bruins ont toujours leur
avis un ca sur les chansons pc des
pme/pmi possible
qui pis les fans les gens qui me suivent
pis les nouveaux qui commence à
m'écouter y en a toujours qui sera
ajouté
c'est vraiment vraiment désolés qui
m'importe le plus c'est la date est pour
eux j'ai les personnes qui m'écrit twh
30-18 ton album en septembre est très
positif accueil qui fait des propres
habits l'album ouais ça fait deux albums
des avocats de ben j'ai toujours fait
des beats sur mes albums
ok sauf que maintenant
des soldats comme avant l'aube suprême
seuls j'avais peut-être fait le
trois-quarts ok mais le franc tout les
beats et deux mois il le dernier venu
des longs couteaux lieu de vie doivent
s'impliquer aussi dans moi mon équipe
pilar et ses mots si tu le fais parler
parce que tu veux avoir des touches qui
a trait sur tout les plans du projet où
tu fais quelles raisons de cette fatigue
plusieurs raisons prévoir parce que je
capable de le faire toi si t'es pas
capable je serai je serai pas les yeux
et me trompe je suis capable de faire de
très bonnes bases
ce qui pourrait à lille comme chercher
est un vétéran du hip hop comme pour
aller chercher n'importe quel
viniculture le tipi s'ouvre est vraiment
du temps ouais mais en même temps tu
sais je serai moins personnellement je
serais content de l'équipe que j'ai tout
entier qui est formidable c'est beaucoup
de maquettes que je te ferai écouter qui
sont pas pareils comme la version finale
son équipe de tonnes que ça reste quand
même similaire au budget fait originale
aux médecins et enfin enfin un bon
travail pour prendre un produit au petit
matin je vois pas pourquoi j'ai acheté
un but à gerland ne rend des beatmakers
10 des musiciens de qualité au québec ce
que j'ai envie d'être avec les gens que
je connais tu sais j'ai envie de pouvoir
rappeler 910 parlé dans ma langue
j'aime beaucoup travailler
j'aime pas soit forcé les collaborations
gmail labs à rapprocher du bonheur pour
les fictions pour ce parce que
naturellement que deux fils de fous
qu'ils ont la bosse est en train de mes
amis qu'on se font si vu quelques fois
dans les derniers mois
pendant que je crée à l'album ça c'est
juste être naturellement pour forcer ses
collaborations à la le mettons
d'habitude le c'est une affaire de
jeunes et schmitt film la boum ou si la
maison
contact maison de disques on arrange on
a faim on fermait maison du style mais
il ya un peu de tout ça en fait tout
s'éclaire le bâton la collaboration se
fait humainement ce à dire que je
contacte la personne directement pour
faire la chanson de l'artiste à
l'honneur la partie sauf que c'est pour
tout chantier réglages de de droits de
douane c'est les maisons de disques inc
deal entre entre elles sur notre mot à
dire sur comment on va répartir sur m 6
et quand même du travail de les modérer
a aussi sur la partie plate moi je le
sens bien manger est ce que je peux vous
dire ex donc l'oeuvre fou qui on est
soi-même maison de soi qui peut qu'y
septième système c'est exactement où
qu'ils ont part on peut parler de la
relève du jazz rock québécois raffoux
qui s'est vraiment un open commune puis
un peu et j'ai l'impression que tu le
prends un peu ce ton aile d'impôts dans
ta ligne et dans ta continuité ouais ça
s'est fait en même temps supporter
quelque chose de calculé jean temps de
prendre ses je veux te prendre sous son
aile et tout devienne mon protégé ou à
la russie encore là ça reste quelque
chose de qui s'est fait naturellement
si quelqu'un qui sait vraiment drôle
possiblement vouloir que je raconte sa
caméra mais c'est un c'est un grand fan
de didier robert souvenait facebook
récemment où je disais je suis c'est un
stade sur mon père mon compte personnel
le dosage a fait un show cégep du
vieux-montréal sur l'heure du midi avec
mon dj hi j'avais fait un statut qui
disait aujourd'hui j'ai signé des cartes
de la stm des richesses de jeunes hommes
c'était vraiment spécial qui en dans les
commentaires j'ai fait photos à l'appui
j'ai posté une photo de 2 2 go il y
avait le tx est signée corée est
évidemment souvenons nous des tags et
man c'est fou ça fait mal goupillé 1 2 2
ap 2 1 exactement puisque pour la photo
mais je sais que tu apprends joke leçon
c'est vraiment ce grand fan de ce que je
fais je trouve ça je trouve ça beau en
même temps si moi je vais maintenant
pour deux mois quand j'étais jeune j'ai
beaucoup d'artistes que j'admirais avec
qui j'ai collaboré après cette ressource
et comprendre que là dessus tu étais un
peu la gratitude clamant pisteurs
personnages comme je vais moi je
valorise beaucoup qui m'admirent ep qui
est rendu à mon style je suis maintenant
six ans
collabore avec moi pas remplir des
salles tout ce soc parlophone puis c'est
quelqu'un qui est réellement tiki et
authentique que tu sais qu'il est très
talentueux aussi c'est à dire que c'est
naturel c'est un dieu qui vit chez nous
je fais écouter des beats pivot chinois
feraient sentir ses tresses et tout cela
sans naturellement pis c'est fou moi ça
m'impressionne à quel point le paysage
du rap au québec change extrêmement vite
pis c'est tout depuis deux ans après une
petite pause puis on va pouvoir revenir
là dessus mais c'est en deux ans
commençait à changer c'est incroyable
c'est maintenant justement tu des
nouveaux noms comme fou qui use that
they a aussi qui est qui se parent bon
là où depuis les huits offrant carrière
solo les des daubes il fera carrière
solo c'est fou comme un kit à l'affût de
souci par exemple le beatmaker leçon
qu'on maintient et le gorille j'ai
rencontré par hasard ces mythes sont
malades y avait beaucoup de je trouve
qu'il ya beaucoup de talents qui
émergent nous deux parties la scène est
très en forme je pense médecins et n'a
pas eu à l'époque sont encore au même
niveau que l'ego c'est à remplir des
salles programmant ses pieds
following des albums pitt est ce que
c'est une question qui en manquent
en terme de talent aussi jusqu'à leur
place n'est pas encore acquise
je sais pas j'ai eues on dirait que le
talent et pau et pose présent que les
gones au rendez vous je sais pas si on
dirait que c'est quelque chose parce que
leurs exploits domaine prodomaines qui
est extrêmement masculin extrêmement
mâle alpha male fois je passais d'emblée
les faits le moyen de modèles la moyenne
jeunes qui veulent un modèle samedi
celle ci aussi connu ça a pris du temps
tu es tout moment lorsque la scène
d'europe aux états unis et est en
émergence jusqu à ce qu des filles se
met à rapper ça comme un peu diminué au
pur et il y en avait une de ses amies
mcm qui avec qui il ya une couple sauf
que c'est qu'on pense ou à l'âge d'or du
rap club le début des années 2000
finaliste il y avait 26 reinmann
coaching va se souvenir de son nom
c'était trop jeune homme est sûr c'est
que ce serait au tour c'est vraiment bon
rain man qui est de la première cassette
de rappeler que j'ai acheté leur premier
single tracks simple patch schilling
quitté fit ce benjing le premier verre
ce qui est sûr la chanson sur bin haji
excellente rapport à la moyenne avec
jack layton qui était super super
féministe dans sa dans sa façon de 2,2
de dénoncer des affaires de ses puits
qui moi me faisais parti social
j'écoutais les mmo aion jeté comme une
chute et un à me faisait vraiment partie
être plus large dans la contrée super
sweet c'était vraiment dans des cas à
lille avec son personnage sur l'album
qui j'ai l'impression qu'ils manquent
il manque un peu de caractère de rap
féminin québécois mais j'ai l'impression
que je dis beaucoup de rappeurs qui sort
de noël j'ai l'impression qu'ils vont
avoir des faits criminels voir plus de
filles que j'ai ce soir je sais tout ça
fait à peu près 20 ans tu fais du rap ça
fait cette année vingt ans que j'ai
commencé à rapper moitié seulement 14
jeux qui depuis vingt et a séparément
maintenant que le rap est le plus en
vogue au québec on voit guéant santé
nouveau de la qualité puis le fait
probablement l'effet l'art dans l'est
dans la dernière année et a joué un gros
morceau dans ce lot il ya eu à attendre
je pense qu'on peut dire quand même un
bail que pas beaucoup de monde avait
atteint avant lui
puis je pense que ça a déjà aidé le
mouvement définitive nécessairement tu
sais quand tu réussis à athènes un grand
public pensait de toutes les femmes
savent danser qui a été pendant un
certain temps la chanson francophone la
plus écoutée au monde c'est quand tu
considères ça c'est sûr qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui doivent entendre
ce à radio qui ont jamais exposé aura
peut-être oui mais c'est avoir le
cerveau n'est pas pour la radio
commerciale également exact c'est quoi
par exemple les numéros en stop
c'est fou ce qui était la première fois
qu'une de mes deux méchants sont pas
vraiment à la radio commerciale ça fait
là ça fait un bout qu'on essaie et c'est
le timing était bon justement parce que
lui je pense qu'il y aura peu lisible
notre entrée à la radio virgin avec son
single qui sait matonge taleo partie de
ces quoi il répond en fait à une soirée
privée où était le seul mois passé j'ai
rencontré des acteurs la programmation
pis j'ai jasé avec lui c'est
concrètement les yeux dans les yeux avec
un directeur la programmation de radio
commerciale qui ça change tout un peu
parce que moi je dis prie juste comment
sont fermés d'esprit prend il veut je
passais de la marde ce j'ai joué avec
lui c'est l'autre se voit s'il ya des
humains derrière tout il ne voit pas
d'issue fatale chanson là et puis j'ai
compris c'est quoi j'ai vraiment compris
ce à quoi j'ai compris d'où tu viens
j'ai compris pourquoi les gens sont lyon
un intrigant latrille envers ceux qui
qui avait déjà la chanson à la doutre
seppi s'est lui même un petit métier en
voyant live y avait quatre c'est quoi
des fois c'est juste soupe c'est juste
de s'ouvrir pour l'esprit d'essayer de
savoir ce que c'est c'est ce qui m'est
arrivé en écoutant occupation de venir
écouter l'émission là dans la saison où
toi tu étais religieusement dit qu'il
est à la fois qui est religieuse
non mais c'est pas pour rien parce que
je me suis donné raison ma blonde à
l'ecoute les téléréalités depuis un bout
quand même de façon un peu assumer en
sachant qu'il y en a dix qui tenait
comme jeu oui mais je trouve ça
divertissant regardez ici j'ai commencé
à regarder occupation double parce que
je connais dames où trônent aussi je
connais comme étant qui puis-je me suis
donné comme raison je le connais je vole
titre je me suis juste vraiment ça me
fait tomber des préjugés parce que
j'avais vraiment l'impression que c'est
un flic show comprenez du monde un peu
byte qu'on les mettait devant gameiro
puis qu'on lui met en cache des
confiseurs spectacle avec sommet par
dessus la main avec votre édition chaque
convention peut changer le cas cette
année où si on change de casting cd
jantes illégaux sont superbes rien sont
respectueux qui les fait aussi sont
sentis sera pas des gens limites
éthiques parce que s'ils voulaient
relancer justement ce concept leur
fallait changer quelque chose je pense
que c'était plus d'actualité dans l'air
du temps les gens veulent pu souffler
puis la b6 le pense oui mais ça
fonctionne ça marche en dépression
saisonnière
vous êtes déprimés pendant toute la
saison avec ce morceau je trouve qu'ils
ont ramené simple loin de prendre des
gens c'est avec une grande vanité
les présentations d'apprendre un saut
d'exon je tombe là d'un mec façon donc
pas du tout justement tu sais j'ai pris
la peine en prenant la peine de
l'écouter
ça me fait un peu tomber les préjugés
mobilise des préfabriqués que j'avais
par rapport à ceux qui pleins de choses
les chats maladie fera radio papa au rap
soit 6 est tombé un peu sous ce qui est
vraiment bluffant de prison parce que
c'est ultra payant n'est pas ça la fout
c'est le premier avantage tend
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui seul ça
change pas si c'est pas bien quand un
symbole mais au moins ça fait on n'a ni
monétairement jeudi sans rentrer dans
les détails et mon état de tous au sein
reste quelque chose combien
cet esthète mène dans chacun des têtes
sauf que ça reste et ça reste mon
choisir ils se sont choisi ce qu'yves
vivre pareil le contrôle des passagers
payants les spectacles des enfants sauf
gauthier l'argent tu le fais pas les
twins millions pour avoir quelque chose
que du bon sens et encore aujourd'hui
toujours là la poule et l'oeuf un peu
aux six autres les a tous connaissent
leur public
seppi a lui causé ces statistiques
comprends leur position
c'est plus qu'un comprend qu'ils ont le
public prouvent que il décide d'un peu
de ce qu'elle publie ce qu'est ce que le
puits justement quand ils sont un petit
peu audacieux qui osent met des chansons
qui sont un peu du cadre privé la radio
commerciale comme moi par exemple mais
se rendre compte que public m sorry you
to city santé chercheurs publics et
allemand ouais parce que les gens
n'écoutent pas un moment il a raté ou
maintenant que les personnes plus âgées
je sais par médecin jusqu'à n'est pas la
démographie je sais pas mais je sais pas
moi je sais pas plus pour imaginer
qu'ils définissent m'a plutôt jeune ceci
suite
oui j'en parle à mon lancement à
montréal il ya un préjugé par rapport à
ça aussi
genre c'est mal vu où c'est un peu ce
petit servait de toit pour insulter
quelqu'un tu fais du rap pour ado puis
si je dis aux jeunes qui t'écoutent puis
ça je trouve ça vraiment en poche quand
tu es vraiment pas donner crédit à
jeûner c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
dommage car maintenant mieux c'est des
jeunes qui m'écoutent le sujet c'est la
génération
chaque génération c'est toujours les
quand tu es jeune qui était la plus
grande ouverture d'esprit sur découvrir
de nouvelles musiques puis il s'est même
prouvé qu'après 30 ans est un artiste
musicien p rester curieux la majorité
des gens découvrent pratiquement plus
une nouvelle musique qui continue
d'écouter ce qu'ils écoutent et quand
j'étais jeune c'est toujours des
exceptions à son mari sa surveillance
compte de tantôt de plus tu vieillis
plus
changer des habitudes de vie sont hissés
changer tes goûts changent et ce que tu
consommes plus tu vieillis plus servir
du style de ton le villa avec les
véganisme commenté notre no cry ccd 18 à
lorsqu'après sûr c'est vraiment très
difficile de faire passer de faire
changer les gens devaient changer leurs
habitudes de consommation mais attire
encore le thé propos qui est personnes
montent aux barricades autour des des
exceptions puis justement de cela il y
avait jean philippe eux tirent sur la
corde qui est chef et vegan devant un
public amateur sur sur facebook pitite
avait foule de commentaires
j'ai 72 ans et je viens je viens de
revenir vegan que je récuse tout cela
n'empire d'accès ça donne espoir
vraiment balustres lulu sus d'une
légende trouverait c'est une autre
exemple vraiment donner une bonne
entrevue mois probablement que je serai
minimum végétarien si la seule chose qui
m'empêche de le faire c'est parce que ça
peut juste ma vie que celle sur laquelle
vont avoir un mac chalamont alimentation
complet cela j'ai deux enfants c'est
vraiment croire je prête à embarquer là
dedans sauf que je sais qu'un jour
j'aurai pour moi il végétarien parce que
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de monde qui
ont cette réflexion de dire un jour type
tout le monde fait son chemin c'est
qu'on ne les rendent marriage une
consommation annoncée on si on ya
beaucoup beaucoup de beaux vg le minimum
de viande
tu te mêles à lever complètement c'est
un petit peu c'est difficile pour moi en
ce moment
j'étais le seul à ses cheveux juste mes
bonbons à ça m'a coupé 2 2 j'avais
seulement moi sans m'occuper d'eux a
tourné c'est plutôt par exemple or
justement dans le truck en revenant de
la bisbille avec müller en tant qu'homme
de là on se fait ensuite des landes
charente partira journée on commence en
face parce que même quand et sa route
l'abitibi lot a pas beaucoup choir santé
mais est gêné mais cela n'a pas beaucoup
plus le temps passe plus ton métabolisme
17 - le ratio mekdoud la tournée c'est
moi
même si les options peu plus d'équité
quand même d'autres options comme un
domaine à mettre des fois de monter
plein thaï express étant mieux qu'un big
mac ici ça la crise sauter jetons
express est serré champlay la france
antilles mais césaire et à l'épicerie
sinon l'on prête à l'épicerie bio comme
blancs des options pour ton post paniers
pleins de fruits et légumes tout simple
on se dit on serait on recommence à se
faire des lunchs parce que c'est
vraiment difficile on tournait des fois
tu as juste des casse-croûte j'écris
rendu été rendu à l'ange d'arrêter aux
épiceries certaines avancées fait que
évidemment que si on fait au doublement
attention à ce qu'on imagine que ton
expérience de tournai changé beaucoup
courant de 20 ans ce n'est pas de la
même façon de sujets dans tous les sens
oui c'est différent
notamment récemment parce que j'ai
arrêté de boire je commence à en parler
publiquement parce que le maroc parce
que ça fait un beau but ça fait depuis
la mis en échec ça fait beaucoup
savaient pas si longtemps sauf que je
dirai tout les mois tout ce que j'ai
envisagé jusque j'appréhendais en fait
je les passe et puis bien je vais le
chercher en d appréhender un spectacle
i'm a man show je me prenais une deux
bières pour décanter après le show avec
lego sortie j'étais dans plein de
contexte il y avait de l'alcool autour
de moi puis retombe pas de problème j'ai
réussi à passer la tentation bij les
traîtres un peu comme la clope parce que
j'ai arrêté de fumer la cigarette a fait
six ans cette année en 2012 qui si je
suis mais pas tant que ça mais je suis
mais quand même c'est plus jamais je m'
à côté c'est beaucoup une béquille pour
le stress plus pur style comme beaucoup
de gens puis j'ai arrêté de fumer parce
qu'à un moment donné
justin fmi en abitibi puis je suis mapaq
est une manne soit horrible j'ai vu mes
poumons lendemain j'étais comme je suis
jamais fan club j'ai arrêté un peu
contre qui joue surtout pour toucher une
clope
puis j'ai fait la même chose mais je
suis vraiment le haut festif de baie
saint paul ne se torcher dégueulasse
pour point où le lendemain j'étais
convoqué chez ces trolls coutrot pis si
je sais pas si je sais pas si je suis
alcool écoute c simple tape à dire parce
que l'alcool est tellement lubrifiant
social de glorifier tout le monde boit
croire comment tout le monde boit qui
quand des pendants salalah la dépendance
un peu mais ça peut devenir
problématique dans certains moments tu
es jeune et pour celui qui vous savez ça
24 tous les jours puis module la journée
sauf que des fois je m'ouvre mk esprit
je l'habille au complexe à avoir
donc j'ai décidé de juste l'enlever de
ma vie qui ça me fait un bien immense
gigantesque on aurait pu avoir de oui
c'est capoté c'est vraiment ces jeux
jamais avoir vu le menu était une fois
dans ma ville trop mois juste pour dire
juste pour essayer si je t'ai pas un
pouvoir excessif non plus métier on est
tous à tulsa dans comment tu te sens le
matin quand titre iv et tout ça
en portefeuille le sens aussi oui c'est
exactement ça
qu'ils soient justement j'en vois juste
des avantages ses besoins pis si j'ai le
goût d'un buzz une fois de temps en
temps mais moi j'ai commencé à consommer
du cannabis de façon responsable et le
glory chance et je peux pas poster des
photos de moi train qui why can't make
le social ils ont sociaux comme snoop
dogg ça je veux pauvre glorifier ce non
plus parce que j'ai eu c'est dangereux
j'espère que la ligue a sonné avec la
prévention au pied
sauf que maintenant c'est sûr j'ai
découvert en fait à cause du week-end
dans l'accord justement toutes les
différences de stress et comment sceller
le puits squatter actif le skip au petit
couac c'est également ce qui fait que tu
peux faire une consommation responsable
quand et éduquer sur le sujet j'ai
commencé j'ai commencé à fumer est sa
main puis dans des moments où j'ai envie
de quelque chose il y en a beaucoup que
je connais comme tu dis lui à la fin la
zone et ceux ci ont besoin de danger si
les habitudes c'est de prendre une
habitude mais quelqu'un sait quelque
chose d extraordinaire qui est pas dans
ton quotidien
c'est beaucoup moins dangereux que genre
je fais avant de coucher à chaque soir
ces derniers une habitude depuis le seul
effet dangereux
les produits alternatifs moi c'est sage
et au thc gens comme je connais des
producteurs de produits alternatifs sont
vraiment formidables c'est au tour du
tout et glacis faisait le thc le site
france2 était glacée puis c'est pas
comme une allée de la grosse bouquin
beaucoup de fumée oui c'est exact où des
des gélules de cbd ou 6 km et on sait ça
ça va l'accepter encore avant le sommet
de séoul et apprendre un métier de
somnifères et des moyens naturels
alternatif à partir du cannabis qui sont
avec avec la ligue la légalisation qui
s'en vient j'ai l'impression qu'il va
avoir beaucoup plus de produits comme ça
qu'ils vont sortir que tu vas voir
contrôler beaucoup plus facilement sans
nécessairement de scrap et les poumons
avec la can c'est moi ça c'est ce qui me
dérange le plus moche et asthmatique
d'envy aussi ce que j'aimerais voir se
respecte c'est ce film m'a dit si jamais
j'ai l'option aussi maintenant d'avoir
fait pas
biscuits leclerc mais temps sec et
telles doses seulement je trouve que
c'est vraiment trouve que c'est en tout
cas pour moi c'est ce qu'ils m'appellent
m'attire le plus je pense dans le dosage
aussi de savoir justement dans le
podcast de dordogne a parlé parce qu'il
part la légalisation de tous les aspects
parce qu'il m'a mis beaucoup de choses à
considérer ces sur simple et moins tu
sais je connais pas trop encore de s'il
faut que je sache sur le sujet puis si
je trouve ça intéressant parce que c'est
ça reste ça reste la drogue ça est une
substance qui peut être nocive pour
certaines personnes qui sont sujettes à
psychose chez terrain puis le dosage on
ne sait pas si tu achètes un regard de
poteaux qui me dit de là quand cette
tâche et gars là dedans petit sait
quelle folle avec la légalisation c'est
justement sur sa brosse l'un d'entre eux
dit contrôle ainsi que 10 mg kg est
entier il ya pour ceux s'intéressant
justement moi j'aime savoir le savoir la
quantité que jamais dans le corps j'ai
pas envie de me défoncer puis ils
devront de plus 5 dans la consommation
puisse en weppes en démystifiant aussi
en démystifiant pian en enlevant le
préjugé qui est connotée négativement en
fait c'est de rendre plus juste accepter
comme sur les gens vont moins sentir
réprimer des enfants ou de consommer du
cannabis il faut que vous croyez qu'un
aspect préventif
c'est important parce que le soc sa
partie un coup ils ont partir en convoi
reprend comme l'alcool dans alcon la
prévention est horrifié que mes jambes
pendant certaines périodes clés de
l'année où plus de consommation d'alcool
c'est une drogue forte on l'oublié un
verre de whisky de ces fortes et
beaucoup plus beaucoup beaucoup plus des
décès qui sont à cause de l'alcool qu'à
cause des brigades rosberg mais je vais
relire aujourd'hui j'ai passé qu'ils
aient des stats
trente huit mille personnes à chaque
année marc à cause de la consommation de
marijuana temps d' accident d'auto à la
finlande jokes aussitôt des stades sur
l'alcool
et justement c'est vrai ça est-ce
quelque chose de même par exemple j'ai
regardé la série boardwalk empire et
pendant la prohibition aux états unis je
trouve ça absurde que l'alcool soit
prohibé parce qu on est tellement
habitué ce soit légal mais c'est si
c'est pas plus absurde que que le
cannabis n'ont pas le talent sans doute
podcast dylan mosquée jama joe rogan pis
c'est le monde font tout un plat avec le
fait qu'ils se fait même toujours un
petit problème prend une pauvre qui n'a
lui même pas la fin mais toutes les
têtes et pas de casser boivent du whisky
c'est mais c'est ça qui est fou qu'est
la prévention aussi parce que de notre
côté mais j'ai des amis infirmière qui
discutent monde en psychose il y en a à
chaque soir 31 hôpitaux à cause du du
cannabis et faut que les gens soient au
courant aussi les enfermant dans les
médias c'est plus une campagne de peur
qu'une campagne de prévention serait
prévisible de la pac à libreville
ouais si c'est dommage aussi c'est
dommage en fait moi je sais qu'il faut
que je le fais car l'aspect éducatif les
gens soient éduqués sur le sujet de sa
forme avant de consommer moins c'est ce
que j'ai fait avant de consommer avant
de commencer à voir des produits chez
moi en sécurité loin d un pack de jeux
jeux qui est selon le terrain c'est
parce qu'il ya aussi des cas d'erreur
est de 2 2 points se ramassent à
l'urgence parce qu'ils ont trouvé les
jeux beurre parenti mais ça n'avance pas
l'arrêter non non c'est exactement pilat
le seul à penser que le thc passe
différemment si ça peut être très
dangereux longtemps
c'est sûr tous ces aspects l'offre qu'il
faut qu'ils aient une éducation qui se
passe puis je prends beaucoup stop ce
que je pose non plus parce que
j'apprends halloween jeunes vous en
parliez fallu un jeune je trouve ça
quand même important de pas faire
n'importe quoi ces réseaux sociaux je
peux faire des séries de moins qu'une
équipe à part le jeu mou quitte ses
jumeaux le goût de pleurer fier ça moi
je le fais pas c'est personnel puis le
jean parrot match propre en parler tant
que sotigui souhaite en parle avec
nuance pis en bois mais c'est ça son
responsable
cette fois qui ce qu'il faut parce que
quand même à parler des conversations là
dessus que j'ai beaucoup de cachets je
consomme puis de façon je pense que j'ai
écouté chemin 5 à 7
deuxième single de ton album tu traite
justement de ce du fait que tu arrêtes
de boire pis que tout les côtés négatifs
de la consommation par le passé sauf que
tu le fais avec un avec un rythme up
beat c'est là tout ne tourne pas jouer à
radio j
c'est un trip c'est drôle parce que je
trouve ça ironique mais exact mais war
francophone c'est quoi tout sauf une
chanson qui parle belgique d'alcoolisme
de problèmes de consommation
ouais c'est ça c'est cool puis ça me
faisait penser et je pense que c'était
oui c'est la tour trump shop ii makoun -
quand c'est sorti mais c'est ce qui est
finalement un sujet quand même assez à
ses potes pas de drogue dans ce que
l'homme est assez sérieux avec un tout
neuf buts ça permet que j'ai
l'impression ce que ça fait c'est que le
message passe beaucoup plus largement
j'ai l'impression que oui mais beaucoup
d'associations ont fait ça quand même si
je pense
pendant tout ce qui amène m a fait
pratiquement effectivement le faire un
peu avec humour avec dérision
d'exagération également aux crs mon
album est très exagéré c'est très
théâtral s'est sèchement soit dans le
rapide dans la musique en général c'est
de prendre quelque chose que tu vis de
prendre de prendre une situation une
émotion pu devenir l'extrapoler puis
l'exagérer puis enfin le notent ils
simple sur la chanson c'est à dire que
j'ai voulu le faire avec un peu du monde
sait ça est quand même là c'est léger
dans le ton même 50 du printemps
d'écouter ce que je dis c'est pas très
léger sourire ça
de lagonda fait c'est l'exagération puis
de trouver le temps pour parler d'un
sujet des fois c est intéressant des
fois c'est le fond de leur premier degré
des fois c'est le fun aussi de faire de
façon un peu plus les gens parlent de
l'alcoolisme en faisant rimer avec le
clip qui accompagne la chanson qui est
vraiment serait pas plus je pense quand
j'ai écouté la chanson parce que tu nous
avais envoyé on avait eu ton album un
pré écoute fait que moi j'avais écouté
la chanson avant que le clip sorte pique
un clip est sorti c'était exactement
comme j'aurais imaginé le clip là des
fois les réalise la chanson plus il ya
des images qui viennent qu'il veut les
rendre
concrètement si les gamins qui réalise
ouais cce
vincent acquis vincent ruel côté qu'ils
avaient des deux gamins qui a réalisé
dans les délais sont surprenants qui est
elle aussi sauf que moi ça décrypte le
chevelu proprement toutes les femmes
sont vraiment bons pauvres et unité qui
réalise eagle jusqu'à potes
17h54 c'est pas ce vraiment servir et
encore une fois grâce à quatre heures
après le premier vidéoclip y était super
directeur cauchemar qui se répète si
d'aucuns avaient éléphants aussi way
exactement celui fêté les femmes puis
qui sait super différentes et on tente
arrive trop vêtements rien ça reste
c'est ça serait déjà un très bon
résultat
c'est vraiment le fun de travailler avec
lui une qui sait on s'amuse beaucoup sur
les plateaux puis si ça ça reste quelque
chose ce qui est important pour moi je
pourrais faire serait quelqu'un jusqu'à
l'époque y est plat travailler avec cg
goût de m'amuser en travaillant puis
même éléphants qui était super dur mais
j'étais naïf on est tellement ri a
tournée solo naway willens drôle c'est
là la scène j'ai mes plans 290 ont des
crampes et après l'été qu'il y ait dans
cette foule excitée de faire quelque
chose qui visuellement d'or que l'on rit
à le faire ça reste quelque chose de jeu
tout entier diffusaient des messages il
s'en va de suite cependant de bien
analyser non non c'est juste stern
puis de faire l'album j'imagine aussi ça
a fait sortir de ma chambre pour toi
exactement ça
c'est ben oui oui sinon c'est pour moi
une thérapie c'est allé voir ma psy mais
pour moi ce sont très rapides mais ça s
oui des fois il ya des moments où des
chansons qui viennent un peu de forcer à
réfléchir sur quelque chose qui t'a grue
qui allait en parler après possiblement
guérir de l'enfant aussi comme la
chanson alerte amber sur mon album qui
est une chanson où je parle que je fous
l'camp anonymement dans un autre pays
mais soucier roussin résultèrent n'ai
jamais eu une fois l'intention de façon
nomade vie c'est mon père c'est pour le
sol chinois
mon parquet qui partira que jeunesse qui
reflète sa vie au brésil ce qui était
commun comme sacrés du vieux os écrit
jose exactement s'appelle de femmes
l'idéal pour le google et même un jeu
monsieur parce qu'aussi de documents
parmi eux documentation naître les
sources et des commentaires sur deux
femmes
exactement qui ont des divisions partout
dans le monde mais ça reste les mêmes
valeurs les valeurs chrétiennes mais des
barreurs son twist petit monde gauche
chrétienne fondamentaliste extrême jaune
exact exactement ce extrême celle qu'il
aime parce que c'est très communautaire
ce soit des gens qui habitent un même
plat sauf que tout le monde couche avec
tout le monde a droit à utiliser ils
font du du phishing c'est à dire qu'ils
vont utiliser des femmes pour aller
faire du recrutement selon les envoyés
puis donc chez bingo pour l'exemple de
la position les filles ont l'âge de
procréer
ce mari font des enfants c'est le fait
que ces jeunes très jeunes en âge de
procréer c'est ça arrive distribuer
c'est exactement dépendant 112 et
septembre
c'est pas que certains diraient dégâts
moi je dois dire lui était là dedans je
commence par jeunesse que tamar était là
d'un certain moment où oui elle était
dedans quand parce que ce qui est arrivé
c'est que ma mère je vous racontais
l'histoire concrètement qu'est ce qui
s'est passé rapidement pas été amoureux
seconde à sion ils sont connus à 12 13
ans on est ici en tout québec ou à
montréal
non ils sont connus à l'école secondaire
comme sa blonde qui on est et le
secondaire ensemble qui les deux
viennent de familles on peut défavoriser
ma mère c'est pratiquement arrivé tout
seul autre service et lcd par action et
ont prêté très présent qui a qui sont un
peu les deux se sont retrouvés dans la
religion voulait donner missionnaire ce
qu'ils voulaient faire il a abandonné
son état place henri-bourassa à
montréal-nord sont tombés sur un groupe
religieux qui chantait la bonne nouvelle
est utopiste de fermer liste des membres
de deux familles qui recrutent et les
chercher on veut l'on veut faire partie
de ça ils se sont joints à rue ont
commencé à rentrer avec ces personnes le
pi s'est avéré de femme lit donc long
des bonnes durant des bons moyens que
vous regardez documentaire vous je
trouve le titre n'en suis pas mais c'est
vraiment ce google de faire vous allez
trop c'est quoi nous avons des bons
moyens pour brancher mon quand même les
environs ap là dedans par seulement des
gens qui sont au pouvoir cherche deux
mâles adolescents exactement qui dans
tout ce qui se passe un moment est
tombée enceinte de moitié
c'est un peu ce qui l'empêché simple ce
qui lui tombait contenant des
complètement exactement parce qu'elles
pensent avons bien être
ils ne m'ont pas lui talib de plein
fouet la dedans puis on va donner son
parti s'établir au brésil sandales au
brésil puis d'établissement pardonner
choix martinique monde est ici c'est mon
boulot c'est sûr que je vais décider de
rester avec moi y aller jusqu'à la
meilleure décision selon moi ça aurait
tout changé d'avis à ce qui est moi
j'essaie de voir ce positivement sadi
est beaucoup mieux du bien qui ressortit
de tous au stade que moi j'ai jamais
vraiment envie de le rencontrer mon pas
mais j'ai eu huit enfants
j'ai huit demi frères et soeurs avec
plusieurs facettes avec une femme puis
une autre unsa recueillons jamais
rencontrés je pense qu'ils étaient bien
occupés pendant dans des tailles de
haies il était et ce qui est arrivé la
bossa pouvoir prétend que c'est marie
avec avec une femme qui veut des enfants
c'est ça s il ne pas abandonner parce
que s'attendait pas à avoir d'enfant ça
risquait de ce que mes seins rebondis
parce que j'ai rencontrés dans les états
membres est parce que moi c'est comme je
dis jamais voulu rencontrer mais en
sachant que j'avais des freins et sain
et vous les rencontriez j'ai voulu les
rencontrer ce genre ouais ok je veux je
veux savoir si titi temps est venu
facebook s'est jamais osé les récrés ou
quelque chose petit encore le china gas
mon trousseau
comment rencontrer mes premiers sets je
vais leur écrire ce que avec la venue
facebook sur son gros avantage de
facebook pin est un atout si ça fait
qu'ils ont des comptes facebook ou s'ils
savaient leur nom est ce parce que maman
a toujours en contact avec son avec la
mère de mon père qui est pour moi
c'était comme une danse extermine tente
quand j'étais petit pas ce que me disait
poster qui la gamme
plus tard j'ai juste et qui a huit
hammam écrit l'histoire et je suis à ma
grand mère chez les ch et je peux
envoyer des photos et d'autres enfants
pleurent m'expliquer avec lui a pas
coupé tous les ponts les cris steria
quand même cosmiques par la samare pied
oui il était charmant chaque année
d'ailleurs quand j'avais 18 ans manioc
temps une perche que j'allais voir que
je pouvais y
bref c'est ça j'ai vu chez moi je
connaissais leur nom fait que l'elysée
j'ai cherché sur facebook j'ai stocké
leurs profils à mes frères et soeurs qui
j'ai jamais osé leur écrire voulons
donner une âme et sans qui a commenté
sur ma page facebook
ce moment mon la fanpage coriace tel cas
le tag est quelqu'un qui connaissait à
trois bières pour lever vous revoir mon
show et par jeune anglais portugais et
ce coup-ci magro d'horizon en somme elle
non plus aux impôts exactement ça
le souffle est en train d'écrire
en fait des mois que ce soit arrivé
parce que à cause de son commentaire je
suis quitté key a de l'eau une longue
conversation avec une demi soeur à se
raconter nos vies puits d'où on vient
qu'est ce qu'elle a vécu depuis mois
entier qui en disant mon nom par notre
père jamais caché ton existence du tout
dès que j'te quand j'étais petit il y
avait une photo de toi sur le frigidaire
nous expliques tu étais qui t'amuse et
que je jouais chez nous ah ouais t'es
toi de moi ça me satisfait quand tu
attends semaines j'étais aux anges et
egypte il pleurait à chaudes larmes
quand elle est totalement abandonnée
mais tu étais tu abandonnes imt et à la
sat est arrêté
en fait ces deux sites mais frei sort
sache que j'existe est vraiment ce qu'on
manie sa fille qui sait ce que je trouve
encore de leurs écrits et puis je
voulais pas leur apprendre l'existence
est enclenchée tu n'as pas envie de
causer ce drame là dessus parce qu'on y
touche pas quelqu'un qui revanchard ou
d'engagement pas envie de faire chez mon
paradis s'est jetée comme moi je savoir
si leur a dit que j'existais avant je
pas au bout de course à mardan femme
était effectivement il savait jeter kit
qui sont tous y ont tout le temps voulu
sauter me voir moi contribution de
logiciels avait tué vos city vie
publique
c'est ça la force et que l'ol avait sa
veste et qui donc m suivait publiquement
ses puits dans la conversation tir où tu
habites qu'est ce que tu fais tous au
dessus j'ai 2005 habite à vancouver on
prend une soeur qui habite à toronto
donc sont déjà au canada fac moment
donné je te colle ni vous hanter que
l'on parle d'eux en 2015 ce que j'ai
commencé par là qu'elle s'est récemment
si l'année d'après en 2016
j'ai dit à mes soeurs fois quand vous
payer le billet d'avion nous enchaînons
sont venus passer quatre jours chez nous
deux messages j'appréhendais ce genre ça
va être encore on se connaît pas
commencé et piment dans l'abdomen heures
qui sont entrés chez une nouveauté dans
le divan colle les mises en face au réel
qui au moment même où était le comme
plus fort que dix ans j'ai quelque chose
de d'inexplicable enfin kim md beaucoup
de points communs dans le caractère dans
des expressions faciales
c'est ça reste quand raymond lien
génétique qui est l'autre qui est
indéniable c'est que fillon est arrivé
s'ils ont pensé quatre jours puis qu'on
était incapable de se séparer a faim on
pourra jouer à pac à sanaa on s'est
pourvu depuis on se parle fréquemment ce
qui tient au courant ils détiennent les
deux que deux enfants aussi bluffé com -
l'action s'envoient des photos on se
mettait lui aussi dit récemment serait
temps qu'on se revoie c'est toute une
histoire belge comme dit la chanson
alerte en bas pour revenir
c'est ce que j'ai fait comme si le smi
n'en pour mon père si je pense à mon cas
ce que je fais et à la fin je reviens
chez nous t il parce que je suis
incapable de face aux puissants reste
comme je dis c'est du théâtre ses
jumeaux le moteur peut ensuite quelqu'un
qui décide et pas bien dans sa vie qui
décide de s'en aller peter firth avait
alerté qui même si pas concrètement ce
que fait mon pain ça reste quand même
beaucoup plus sur lui la chanson que
moitié et quand je dis que du pouce et
pierre sortie de saussure que
l'existence de tirs c'est de ces femmes
look sont formidables et je vais encore
plein de gens rencontrés parce qu'il
plaide françois que j'ai pas encore vu
siècle j'ai parlé sur internet mais
quand même c'est quand même spécial si
ce n'était pas arrivé ces personnes-là
extraits puis moi je serais pas où je
suis moins bien en ce moment un pied ça
je sais vous d'avoir de la gratitude au
lieu de deux
maroc tout d'abord des ressentiments va
mon humeur
c'est arrivé parce que cela devait
arriver même si je crois pas que rien
n'arrive pour rien je trouve que c'est
un petit peu absurde mais c'est qu'il
est tellement jeune à l'époque ou cités
est manéo sûr j'ai c'est d'être
conscient verse aux six mètres mais sans
contexte que c'est des ados l'enfant
un ado tu es complètement sex-toy nadeau
lui avait tué mardi sept lui 19 quand je
revois 19 ans tu as tort je l'a
particulièrement peu perdu dans vie tout
ça j'essaie d'être le plus les mains
sont sont des gardes et un peu moins
dans moins de 20 ans vers lui que je
n'ai plus vraiment sèche comme je suis
un peu plus compréhensifs ils si au
final c'est moi qui est mieux là dedans
parce que justice j'essaie de bien vu
avec ce que je vis mieux avec ce
justement depuis qu'elle s'est jetée
musarde pièce que lui tu encore là
dedans des familles
la secte explique exane et je pense
qu'il plus d'un ces enfants sont pas là
dedans non plus non plus par des led à
l'arrière français résoudre qui sont
encore dans la dans l'adolescence mais
qui vient d'eux qu'ils ont eues il y en
a eu sept la même famille la même heure
il ya cette sortie moteur de 30 montrant
30 à 14 ans quelque chose comme ça il y
avait encore la boue pilote le tabac
rencontré jamais non est-ce que tu
commençais tout va peut-être un jour
elle rencontre il faut bien savoir où je
pense pour si ça se peut que jamais une
occasion se trompe pas même pas montréal
le saint marc est décédé fac ci vient
pratiquement jamais aussi vrai pour
venir sa main je pense pas que ça arrive
sauf que si l'occasion se présente qui
ont quand même place en même temps je
serai pas non sauf que je veux pas
forcer sur jupes aux juges aux récents
pas l'appel faisons quelque chose
d'organisé jurent vraiment pauvre % pour
la vie je ressentais vraiment envie de
rencontrer des princes c'est incroyable
comme expérience accessible aussi que
j'ai réglé sauf si on a beaucoup parlé
dans des chansons avant sa sortie
quand même j'ai rêvé que je mens pas je
me serais bien en érection sur ton album
signer un excellent point de plus
sauf si c'était atroce et un peu fait
partie un peu de lait la noirceur la
chanson de l'album si j'ai envie plus il
importe à quoi je rêve d'arriver tout en
[Rires]
[Musique]
un clin d'oeil
oui dernières masses ça me fait penser
que tu dis en cas de pareille menem ces
drames a eu le fuel avec machine gun qui
rit puis moi je programme est une
machine gun kelly je lis trouvait bonnes
fêtes
l'élu et je préférais la réponse des
mines m sauf que jean la tournée bonne
machine quand kerry sauf que ce que ça
fait c'est qu'après seul j'ai surtout un
petit peu dans dans le chai dj deep in
important parce que quand j'écoutais se
jeter jeunes pij petit je t'écoute plus
émané mes joueurs que tu fais le chanter
le refrain mais quand tu portes
attention à tout ce qu'il dit aimer mais
milliers savage depuis jour est un point
hallucinant moi j'ai appris à rapper en
écoutant ses fruits ce temps la radio
mon âge que je commence à rapper matonge
avait eu maintenant quand je pense
vraiment découvrir le rap pia peaufiner
mon écriture tout ce qu'un side
cette entrée puis c'est les années où il
y avait les lily première plateforme de
dans l'autre comme les moyens
vainqueur avec 66 familiale il y avait
eu un coût de 2 des freestyles la radio
qui était comme diverciné dj kheops tel
lui sinon comment c'était donc c'était
un peu comme ça que j'ai appris à pcc 1
techniques d'écriture ccqab hôtesse a
toujours des doutes qui fait rythmique
son flow et un crochet ouais c'est ça
c'est perçu un peu technique douce et
l'absence par toi qui es moi j'ai zappé
l'obsession compulsif sur la technique
décrit comment les rythmes côté multi
mais mais je trouve que le yoyo reflets
verts qui manque maintenant qu' il
intéresse un peu sur ses albums ce que
je trouve dommage que ce qui arrive
souvent ce moi ce que j'aime beaucoup de
certains artistes comiques sont capables
de durer dans le temps comme jay-z par
exemple évolué en tant que personne et
en tant qu'artiste sont neuf suit son
évolution sérieuse bon qu'est-ce qui
fait comme musique mais madame je
m'inquiète un peu
j essaie de rattraper un peu qu'est ce
qui fait avant ça marche pourtant ce qui
se passe et l'évolution de kanye west
sauf là parce que les gens gèrent le
poème de leonard cohen stracke son poème
le coma ce que tu fais comme une fois
qu'ils me briefe les gens aiment se
mettent à haïr quelqu'un je trouve ça
plate
moi j'ai besoin je regardais le 15 mai
noté que dans notre chambre
3 ça triste match de quarts à ce qu'ils
voient pas batman pied chez le berceau
qu'est ce que tu fais
avec une oeuvre qu'un quand l'artiste en
a tant que tu n'aimes pas l'artiste
comment tu gères son oeuvre quand on
parle à personne mais tu aimes le moins
c'est sûr mais c'est pas ce qui en reste
quand même assez personnelle mais moi je
peux capable de consommer la l'oeuvre de
quelqu'un que je trouve vraiment
aberrant
oui je vais la mesure avec ceux avec
agnès que c'est terminé pour toi ben je
trouve pas bien si je trouve choqué je
trouve ça dommage ces positions qui
prend pied trouvant fois qu'une
superficiel ce bain de la ferme éthier
son dernier album sont 7 3 qui est sorti
j'ai trouvé des super bons des ti aidé
par exemple l'on était des fois derrière
certaines chansons sa première chanson
sur son album s'appelle ce feeling le
tout le monde l'a déjà eu un degré ou un
autre mais pour beaucoup de gens qui
arrivent à l'isep et georges j'aime
beaucoup ce aussi chez certains
humoristes certains stand up est capable
de dégâts dans le les intérieurs de le
sortir d'en faire quelque chose de le
dire des conneries alors mars au foyer
moudat love you et puis 10 des affaires
comme ça on ait c'est moi j'admire ce au
seuil est pas juste dû l'être gagner je
trouve qu'il ya un aspect qui me désole
que mange admettre et puis ça reste
quand même toujours bon musicalement
migaud s'est fait que tout ce qu'a
produit aussi parce que contient cet
album pour nous c'est un choix que de
nazes qui accuse l'autre aussi l'autre
d'avant et avec les pochettes était bon
que ça reste au niveau de la production
pour moi c'est le peuple puis quand
j'écoute la musique j'ai entendu
qu'annick je trouve dans les dents les
beats est ce que c'est une influence
baisse soit une influence mais cette
influence disons est ce que tu as fait
consciemment ou non
c'était je pense que tout le monde mais
les artistes échos de la musique qui
consomment des musées qui sont
inévitablement influencées par ce qu'ils
écoutent pas ce que tu mets ton sipa
force et se pose volontiers
parce que tim est en débit ceppo à la
jack on attend plus huppée station leur
maintenance est ainsi mes titres somme
peut vraiment aller dans cette voie
lente et plus je préfère drake dans ce
que j'écris j'écoute plus de jaurès à
matonge écoute plus de beaucoup plus
plus de cani capable du meilleur et du
pire sur sur de l'unfpa blue je trouve
que d'être einstein la première sur la
bible je trouve que c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre essayons ces footeux
d'autres accès comme une égale n'égale
un bon exemple justement et traction tcs
encore le ca s le choix de l'artiste un
mois ce sont je pense que si son feeling
comme vous le rende le pitch et je sais
quand même l'écouté du début à la fin
même s'il aimait mes chansons de jean
paul anka soit c'est juste ce qui me
plaisent moins 10 sauf que ce ça reste
sur un gars qui fait des albums des
albums c'est mieux que ses concurrents
n'a rien fait mon album préféré des
peuples qui est là d'un bout à l'autre
c'est bon chez moi c'est incroyablement
mon prono férus de kayes ségou radios et
chaînes c'est moi je pense pas que son
meilleur mais c'est mon père sont fermés
celui qui quand est sorti j'ai vraiment
panier de quoi puis-je à l'écouté le
grip est un homme parlant longtemps même
si je pense qu objectivement sont beceem
c'est le premier sauf que ça reste quand
même c'est très audacieux puis inventé
il ya inventé une sonorité qualité avec
ses beats avec les samoa super singulier
que je trouve ça plate le poète le poème
de couronnes j'ai presque j'ai trouvé ça
un peu restée des cd rom n ya pas de la
même chose
je ne sais pas vraiment qui tu parles en
disant j'ai comme un des artistes les
plus brillants de quoi tu parles
il sort de la musique cd tous importants
mais ceux se ses suivants générationnel
que tu penses que tu comprends mal la
génération qui suit - puis je prendre la
sienne c'est là ce que je trouve proche
ce qui est beaucoup de gens de la
génération précédente qui comprennent
complètement ce que c'est le même sort
puisque en écoute puis qui y en a
d'autres je pense qu'ils comprennent pas
ou qui prévoit la peine d'écouter les
pics à chevaux sais quoi parce que je
prends un bébé c'est le moi j'écoute du
leonard cohen j'ai commencé à faire
c'est j'écoute beaucoup de rap à ce que
je sais pas qui ne brille maintenant si
ça ressemble à rien d'autre
la façon d'écrire du rapt puis moi c'est
ça qui m'a fasciné dès le début multi
des jeunes je vais jeter j'écris je
termine c'est quoi ce genre là au juge
comprenez la poésie de daniel bélanger
puis si c'est là que je trouve sa poche
ont réduit ce soir style musical wiwa un
or qui abrite situent les pas du tout
mais quelle image son image publique
nuit à sa musique qui s'amusait qui est
beaucoup meilleurs que lui ces
apparitions publiques s'estompe fait
maintenant je passe ses nuits à lui
donne la visibilité ces sources hockey
quand même monde qui connaissent kanye
west mais qui compte c'est comment les
nouveaux supports sont des gens plus
jeunes connaissant le talent d'artistes
ils sont vêtus et au complet puis
j'écoute tout ce qu'il fait mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on se fait concept
chauds lait par exemple et je pense que
toutes tes schizos fait que les
promesses que tout ce qu'il dit ou si
ils pensent vraiment à ce qui se passe
vraiment sommes tous nous tous à ses
deux seins stone pour faire parler de
lui
je pense que je pense que
il n'a pas caché ses pour la santé
mentale quand même pas si je pense pas
que tu sais pas jouer dans des livres
d'incidence si s'écoute parler beaucoup
pis il s'emporte sur des affaires qui
ont ni crainte ait pas céder sur twitter
quarante huit exactement son livre de
philosophie son niveau philosophique
médiation existence qui parlait des
dissimulations le pays essaie d'en
marquer dans les sélaciens mettons qu'un
cheminot de match quatre jours le guen
parle de simulation c'est c'est long
beach ayant partie quand même fait
explique sékou exporte peu car ils ont
vendu simulation quelqu'un enfants qui
m'ont ça atteint mon éthique pour monter
sa table pourquoi je pense que juste
qu'il est depuis lors ce moment il est
un peu cinglé et c'est comme les billes
dans les pommes moi je me demande tout
le temps si c'est pas planifié c'est pas
ça profite à toi y en avoir un vif émoi
ma demande sa bile ips tupac mnm puis
machine girl il avait l'impression a pas
besoin
madame a pas besoin de ça je pense pas
parce que peu
touche à tout pour son statut de légende
du meilleur je pense qu'il est bien dans
ce stade cela peu importe comment c'est
à bon droit et de bon repos ils vont ils
vont vendre
je pense que son album sur son dernier
mot avant-dernier en fait est la preuve
de sens parce que sur l'album qui selon
moins médiocre quand même parce que c
est madame c'est moi qui ai son amende
après je pense que c'est repris je pense
que uma thurman qui pas que je pense pas
que besoin de machine gun kilian's en c2
en fait de ce fait à des stands sur son
album est un peu tous ici tout à fait
c'est juste qu'ils voyaient toujours
fait sauf que dans des périodes où ça
marche un peu plus si seulement mais
mais en ce moment je trouve que ça fait
encore traite encore le monde fagiht sur
ces titres si tu as qu'en 2018 le seuil
est pas changé sont l'excès qui s'est
pas adapté j'ai aussi ceux qui s'est
adaptée complètement la viande du christ
m'a plus haut qui était le rif il est
black women c'est complètement autre
chose
ce qu'ils y vont avec son âge tu avais
d'ailleurs la joue
dans ses malheurs manami madame je pense
c'est quoi même si ça atroce que je sais
que même si je pense qu est un petit peu
moite et pas très affiné comme personne
ça paraît dans ses opinions dans sa
façon peut-être que ça paraît plus sa
musique qui séparait affiné non plus je
pense qu'il peut stagner musicalement il
paye je pense pas qu'ils écoutent bien d
affaire il n'ya pas exploré djezzy par
exemple beaucoup
musicalement awards je pense que ce qui
fait que s'ils pensent qu'il peut pas
faire de meilleur album qui fait en ce
moment est venu parce que à cause de sa
personne
c'est un jugement c'est juste un instit
m une constatation
j'ai l'impression que maintenant c'est
la musique qui pour la musicalité y est
pour beaucoup
même dans le rap qui est basé
principalement sur les paroles le bit
puis la musique y est pour beaucoup
quand j'ai l'impression que cam et on
t'écoute toutefois d'aucun doute la mort
on dirait que tu peux pas retomber dans
un bide comme au school comme eminem
fait si on dirait que c'est rendu
ailleurs jacquet la nouvelle borne mélo
mais n'a pas vraiment choisi de quoi
bomber de kendrick de retomber à quelque
chose de points la baisse et pires
ordinaire puis d'accord c'est vrai que
quand cinq ans mais la baule
musicalement c'est un peu comme si jari
faisait juste de la musique qui porte
parole ces changements surviennent front
to back des hommes se sont approchés
comme je suis moi j'approche mais
d'abord je ne comprends pas du tout et
kenzo etc mais c'est si le design qui
s'écoute pas la pièce les quotas la
pièce c'est hors contexte donc on
parlait de la thonaille de kindu et que
tu as le brasseur sur les côtés comme
moi aussi je n y ai le tuer
c'est la version sur la box de versions
live
et encore plus intéressant c est un coup
de génie du barça capable d'amener une
toune qui en contexte et je sors quand
dans une société où est ce qu on carbure
au single de faire une toune qui est un
gardien qui ça fait pas trop l'album le
incroyable s'est étonné un euro ça met
une grosse claque dans face quand
j'étais très salée pour la première fois
j'ai enrichi
je me demande avec quoi y'a la rue après
après son premier album qui était
incroyable mais avec des mixtapes c'est
que j'ai dit ouais ouais c'est elle sur
son premier album qu'elle voit sur son
deuxième album c'est un manant t il
c'est sûr je me mordais avec quoi ils
avaient été arrêtés à la yann galy
complètement ailleurs des qu'harmonix
ans le jazz pis le piler pop chez le
maire lucien jazz à ces capotes
d'ailleurs est le line up de musique le
travailler sur le cul de quincy jones
une réflexion sur ses débuts une
conversation de courte conversation
entre l'epic wyn jones
mais ce genre de jeu fait un album qui
mélange monsieur pasqua le titre il
mélange le rap il le jazz puis avec
comme typiques d'arik air par les
énigmes qui dit ceci une grosse
influence pour monter d'un cran le
premier mélange du jazz budget et ça me
fait un peu ce soit juste un peu pris
cher vers le jazz c'est difficile à
écouter dessus j'aime les j'aime le jazz
mais ce qui est plus un petit peu plus
léger et c'est parce que ce qui est
super charger en tissu rouge et de
l'avoir écouté souche proche prendre le
muscat main mais pas trop près 1000 jazz
donné le goût d'en écouter écouter les
suprêmes de notre album après ça mais
c'est un pays où citi j'ai pas voulu
m'approprier cette oeuvre du pull un peu
l'arrogance derrière le personnage sur
mon album ça fait partie de tout ça on
peut le dire je prends le titre du pire
album de jazz jusqu'à l'iss à son album
de rap game c'est même pas même pas
achevée dans l'album de jazz de signal
telle autre je pense qu'il ya quelques
puristes qui ont été insultés pense que
oui je me dis c'est que j'ai gagné le
félix de pour l'album love supreme bras
lors du gala de l'adisq qui redoutent un
lucien anglophones que j'ai aucune des
six qui assure joe qui me voient et
africaines insultes etc ça s'appelle lab
suprême le chef à lui de la prendre en
compte et j'explique pourquoi j'étais
gamin je comprends la réaction match
c'est une chose c est reçu comme j'ai
appelé mon la banque comme son petit
chapeau sticky coach maîtriser le titre
si c'est volontaire
six ans que le jazz est un milieu que je
connais un peu comme si j'étais ici en
jazz adversité à musique puis cinq
milieux que dans lequel je trouve un peu
quitte eu autant que des mentalités ce
pas progresser ses parts on va essayer
d'écrire et monter une nouvelle affaire
qui étaient des gens vraiment furieuse
conservateur pis il faut respecter les
easy qu'on les géants du cac sont peu
touchés à sopi on prend taquet mettez
moi j ai aussi le comédien emmanuel
schwartz si vous connaissiez ce genre de
comédie soit sa tronche il est excellent
d'ailleurs mais je fais une batte avec
un moment donné je vais raconter ça ça
lui emmanuel moins 50 salariés le bifff
dans la mine mais watson et ben watson
qui est un de mes amis depuis 15 ans
randonnées jeux terroir gang à montréal
puis émana choix tu es venu voir un peu
chaud pour me dire non pas un jazzman se
taper ton album love supreme but est
comme un peu insulté piscine yam et avec
au micro des bars pour mettre 10 dans
son bloc notes jetées comme mais non
plus de sortir d'album tu vois tu fais
ça dans ma phase j'aime défendre
l'un des courriels pour s'excuser
georges pour violences provoquées puis
j'ai subi son seul un exemple je pense
qu'ils étaient insultés que j'appelais
mon album love supreme je trouve qu'avec
je comprends je peux trouver ça je
trouve sur les jets l'impôt calculé je
pense pas que les puristes car été
insulté par ça il ya salué les factures
elle habitait ouais ouais c'est ça de
l'attaquant une fée minorité wii party
ferment parce que mon fanboy ces coupes
pas est-ce que ce que tu fais encore du
freestore la question est est ce que tu
as déjà dit non mais c'est pas du
freestyle récemment les barreaux de word
up tout prix je sais que c'est sur le
sport comme son ensemble ces prix écrit
je n'étais pas commencé qu diffuse la
nuit je n'ai fait un peu mais pas assez
longtemps pour pouvoir en faire par
exemple un autre un exemple mais bien
watson qui selon moi le meilleur
freestyler et je veux dire je suis chez
eux pendant un deux harpies 1h30
là-dessus freestyle est souvent tout le
pas et bien c'est tout un simple parce
qu'ils m'appellent jafar si le chic
struthof campus sait trop par l'apa est
bon je commence à me pratiquer chez nous
en france italie tu sais quand je vois
le maître en matière de flux
mais petit freestyle chirac le repos je
vois pas comment je peux recommencer à
fruste avoir jugé par des intérêts afin
non plus fait que son offre
j'ai tellement difficile c'était le
moment cette affaire qui m'impressionne
le plus ils partagent votre quinquennat
ma sacoche justement au palais de
congrès tantôt kendrick un café chez
mathilde et foyers dans des choses plus
gaies que des cartes bleues de même
qu'un dieu qui rappe il rappelé en un
mot il faut qu'il dise le mot avant que
la carte change
je ne me sers continue l'erreur ça me
fait quelque temps c'est incroyable elle
beaucoup de son bord sur sarre peu comme
par l'impro
de l'improvisation rim est tout sauf que
la même chose à dire que s'ils font
dessus pratique les improvisateurs ayons
des répétions des pratiques qu'ils ont
c'est quelque chose qui se fait sur des
années notamment dans l'arène jour au
lendemain plus tard les doigts par
l'impro du pratique fou de sa chute du
titre et puis mnm saint lô qui est un
excellent freestylers puis on a beaucoup
québec quand même pire des ligues de
sotchi déjà fait partie le 10 10 15 ans
à peu près y avait là et les hq la ligue
d'improvisation époque du québec qui
dans la fondation de la et les
acheteuses c'est là que je trouve un set
up and coming mais des chansons sur
internet j'ai participé à certaines des
répète j'étais quand même pas payer sauf
que je te passe est motivé pour
continuer il
c'est vraiment difficile hier dix ans
plus tard l'heure des excellents plus
tard au québec notamment des tractions
conasysed de gatineau évidemment rien
maintenant mais des tractions à un très
bon buteur puis fouille a fait ça
récemment j'ai vu une vidéo de lui
asseyait s'aiment ou se fait sortir dès
mon les fruits star à partir des
pompiers super aguri raté tout le temps
mais c'est parce que une aisance était
commun il ya comme quelque chose qui se
déclenche tout était en mode freestyle
moi je les sais je n'ai pas assez
pratiqué pour l'amour je pense que je
pratique la vraie pour le phare le
faudrait je suis motivé cerveau
incroyable s'est développé des réflexes
piscine et quick il souvent d'avoir une
coupe de goto si tu dois avoir des
sujets où est ce que tu vois tu vois le
sujet leur beau succès confortable de
certaines certaines sonorités qui peut
aller l'un des deux équipes même des
patois des phrases répétées un comme moi
je me souviens que je disais tout un
fork date le patois de personnes
[Musique]
exactement comme c'est dramatique de
moai en cuissard et ainsi comme ça que
ça cependant c'est comme ça que ça se
passe le cap sur les côtes fêlées
starlette sur marque et bien sûr que ça
te permet d'aller chercher des idées de
rafah avec gaza prêtre un accès comme
dédé des réflexes de freestyle
accessoire qui est complexe puis quand
c'est bien fait quand c'est pas bien
fait c'est plein temps nestea écoutés
par leurs poches de cristal qui qui va
zy qu'il entama hexagone étoile à
hollywood à kehl la nuit à faire ce que
vous voulez qu'on lise détruire votre
livre les esprits se rendrait
aujourd'hui cool mais qu'est ce qui s'en
vient ce nom en terme de spectacle ça
reste quand même assez smoot monotone
c'est que je ne coupe de choses qui
attend noël maintenant une dizaine de
chevaux mais sans être plus présents
étaient sur le ca commence à ce bouquet
ti qui s'est sans cesse mon spectacle ça
restera mon spectacle de lancement c'est
les chansons du nouvel album quelques
chansons les albums précédents qui a
tourné va être plus mou parce qu'il
n'est pas pour moi mais 1059 torcher les
houblons m soit justement c'est arrivé à
val d'or et rouyn noranda
puis les musiciens sont sortis après
s'être fixé lendemain j'étais frais
comme une rose
quand tu fais du monde en veut tu es
contente pas très clairement ça reste
quelque chose qui est personnel je le
juge pauthe et les jeux des gens doivent
faire ce qu'ils veulent maintenant moi
je suis plus goûteux 30 quand le marché
va doubler qui était déjà en train de
penser à la prochaine musique tu as tout
dit qu'il allait peut-être à 180° 180°
parce que je pense pas que ça aurait
trouvé dramatique au monde en erreur
comme l'année de façon je pense tu avais
pas le choix d'adressé quelque chose
puisque le fait maintenant tu peux pas
faire autre chose parce que c'est
vraiment une page tournée exerçant la
scène crise de passe proche de ma vie
l'adresse est quand même de france pour
l'album qui le mans des gens qu'on passe
à autre chose je pense que de travailler
sur un prochain album sans être sûr de
tourner la page
puis aussi il ya possiblement projet
collabos avec fu chi kung commencer je
change en parle publiquement mais c'est
bien concret on serait peut-être la fin
de travail et quelques chansons ensemble
peut-être senti quelque chose c'était
moi j'ai jamais eu jamais rencontré
personne qui me donne le goût de farce
dans l'élite en dessous de ses deux
parents dans la boum ça se fera
naturellement d'être vécue rien dans
différents paris salle est ce qu'on est
différent mais complémentaire qui ça les
titans que les chansons fonctionne si je
pense qu'on peut faire mais sont joints
une soixantaine d'enfants
moi je suis complémentaire à son style
pilule mais je pense que c'est ce
puissant former un groupe nécessairement
c'est juste être un album
sinon si je conçois travers les chansons
s'arrête jamais vraiment ce jeu contenu
de ce nom en mettant mort dans mes temps
libres jeudi beach et les chansons quand
même je fais mon travail c'est mon hobby
c'est exact ça roule
merci au coup ça fait plaisir cette
magnifique bague de québec
est-ce donc c'est ça en finisseur comme
ça tout le monde moi